Артем якщо 24 чарівня багатий укритики в
Кремля з поділася на ті що заколотий
пригожина продемонструючи в різні новини
путінського режиму Олена рази Путін нема
і на світі добровину ведьмовата севід
Влада прошу світшот підготовка до
виборів тому силові Шлях видає собака
тим експертом одним із найму найвірніших
сценаріїв зміни Влади в Росії
владна смугові перевороти єдиний на
явні механізм для такої Що таке
зрада режиму альтернатив два ланцюг
увільних Мітя режим відпочинок язичного
відходу володеймера Путіна на обвал
фронту і подалі і зростання по трусії
надчастими чого воюють одна зодну тому
рушники скроневий переворот ціни
тому палацова або військова природа
найкраще що може нас чекати Однак на
вимкнений ще писано вдав його заколоту
в
Кремлі
висунувши кисліше до них Вертикаль Влада і
тільки зміт ​​снилося А у потенційних
учасників заколоту поменше конячка
успіх як з людиною працює один і
той же із системи Як із людиною іншу
тієї самої принцип все ще нас не буває
робот нас найсильнішим і А в побут та систему
ніхто надовго намагався йшлося
ролей і я думаю ще німа а не тих хто
мить би оскаржено лідерство Путіна а не
лідара в людині хоч організованих
влаштованих груп та гемоглоб тут на це
переворот Чо заколот які могли б
здійснити
схоже на можна було б тихенько від
Руїни та вінпу мерба видно фарту я до
багату папороть проти ніяких
Путіна обох генерали
президенту Путіну потрібно було
показник приклад може Євген
перехожин у ченнета заколот створений і на
безтурботний прецедент і вичавлений цеделів
іншим людям ідеї топарти інсілюди екіс
стежила потім все сталося побачив і
душі театральний ефектний спосіб
порождения спровожденным він із Роб [ __ ]
виставка та гілку рукуються та владний
розрих він украв мову подібну
загроза і сну і для тих хто разом з
прихожим брав участь у заколоті
і
ще будуть подалі тому що за раз Уси
командори пвкнера знають, що Путін не
прощай і на цей ремонт
знаходиться педзахрозу тільки методи
занедбані такої загрози одна одній
повстанці Путіна та боротися за свої
житія
і третій спосіб приїде
Путін Миколи на прощаю своїх ворогів у тому
у набити в ступ до російської армії
негарантуючого не виживуть
на думку експертів режим за піцумками та
у далеку заколоту можна працювати ставку
на менеджер ефективних алабіль з
контрольованих людей якщо Кремль буде
продовжувати
на вину на виїзд на дружину вона заощадження
статус квоту йому телком дістати нематою
шойгута гора самованахай неефективних
Алле абсолютно лояльних корівнаків та вин
не експериментувати людьми ти по
додана Яким може бути і більше
ефективними Алла зачепиш доводять
теплоти
у кремлі та оточують експорти наврядших
умовах А краще можете ситуацію на
фронті стати загрозу для режиму Путіна
були надії на Тобто кожний ще був
з подіну України це захисних
союзників на контур наступ все Сподіваюся
вона закінчена
курячим переломом на кістку України
у Криму перевороту вискова параске на
донку експертів і знову йому вірність
падіння режиму в разинаростання
внутрішніх конфліктів у Росії допустимо
розпочнуться відпад регіонів пропустимий
розпізнати собі патрохіо ніфпіцентру
топідуть відцентрові тенденції кейзарос і
так сильніше а Дже у нас я регіон та Київ
Самустиної основи житловим значно
найкраща у забрудненому багатшому і так далі
нижче середини Російської Федерації від
того що скриплю Російську Федерацію
зграї зі шкіряним дадали менше
скріплює Російську Федерацію
стає з кожним днем ​​все менше і
менше